today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
below this video
welcome to the program uh voting is
happening now and it's happening early
in record numbers we've talked about it
on the bonus show we are going to do a
deeper dive into these early votes next
week but i want to talk about voter
fraud for a moment i'm sure you know if
you've been watching the show we're
paying attention
to either left or right wing media
because frankly it's been a story on
both although with dif with different
angles
republicans have been going on and on
and on about
in-person voter fraud for years and
almost
every actual case of in-person voter
fraud has been republicans we had the
situation out of north carolina
we've had republicans supposedly
supposedly trying to
test the system and getting caught
committing voter fraud
that's in person we now have a
q a non-aligned mail carrier caught
for allegedly hoarding and throwing out
bags of mail donald trump claims that
the postal service can't handle
mail-in ballots but of course it can and
then
in comes a pro-trump q anon mail carrier
and gets caught allegedly making the
mail
not work special agents reportedly
raided the home of a mail carrier in
baldwin pennsylvania over the weekend
because they got a tip from neighbors
that there were bags
full of undelivered mail being thrown
into the trash
and according to the pittsburgh city
paper
that individual is sean troche his
social media
profiles are filled with all sorts of
extreme right-wing
q anon related references to satanic
pedophile memes
which allege that the media is covering
up child
sex trafficking it relates to pizzagate
and all sorts of other nonsense
also his social media profiles refer to
the
tyranny of coronavirus quarantines and
lockdowns
and uh as we know that uh
perception of tyrannical
recently led to a plot to kidnap
the michigan governor gretchen whitmer
so this stuff has real consequences
according to kdka neighbors
reported that postal service asia agents
raided the home of this mail carrier and
confiscated eight large
garbage bags of suspected undelivered
mail
that this mail carrier repo reportedly
put
on the curb to be picked up with the
week's garbage
a statement from the usps office of the
inspector general says that quote
special agents recovered several
different classes of mail
including business mail flats and small
amount of class mail we expect to
perform a piece count
of the mail tomorrow and make
arrangements to have
the mail delivered to customers as soon
as
feasible now importantly i guess no
particular mention of whether there were
absentee ballots in the mail one way or
the other
although they may not identify the
absentee ballots
by any uh um uh in any way other than by
the class of mail that they represent we
just don't know whether there are
absentee ballots
found in the the bags of trash neighbors
believe that troch
has trashed undelivered mail in the past
no charges has as of yet have as of yet
been filed and this is mirroring
the entire in-person voter fraud ruse
perfectly republicans have
been complaining about in-person voter
fraud and rigged elections
for through mail-in ballots this year
and you've got a q anon guy
caught allegedly hoarding and dumping
mail much like they've been talking
about the in-person voter fraud for a
long time
and almost everybody who gets caught is
is a right winger and then you've got
trump's postmaster putting in place
orders and guidelines
to prevent the timely delivery of mail
across the country
we've seen california republicans deploy
these fake decoy ballot boxes
we've seen republican governors and
secretaries of state
blocking early voting purging voter
rolls
it's them we even saw after the 2016
election republicans in the senate
including the senate majority leader
mitch mcconnell
not even bringing to the floor for
debate
bills to deal specifically with election
interference
including from foreign countries but
even domestic interference as well and
on and on and on so almost without
exception
the rigging and the tampering with
absentee voting has been from
people on the right it is projection
it's undeniable yes it's stunning but at
this point is it even really surprising
and what do republican senators think
about this guy caught hoarding and
trashing mail
this is the real election fraud and it
should be prosecuted
they seem to have made the decision
maybe they made it implicitly it doesn't
have to be an explicit decision where
they sit around and they say
if we don't do this stuff we will lose
but they seem to have
recognized that they have a much
better shot at winning and maybe their
only shot at winning
is if they try to cheat and it's not
just
the right screaming mail fraud when
there isn't any
it's the right screaming mail fraud when
they are the ones doing
the mail fraud of course this instance
as far as we know was not coordinated by
the republican party but again
what they tell us we need to be worried
about
because of the left we really have to be
worried about it because of the right
that's the reality and we will continue
to track whether charges are filed and
of course they should be
and whether there are more instances of
this hey this is super interesting
republican governor charlie baker from
massachusetts our governor
has announced that he cannot support
donald trump for president
and will not be voting for donald trump
now i've mentioned before
that massachusetts has this habit of
electing
sort of moderate republican governors
bill weld as an example
mitt romney not really a moderate but in
the modern republican party
certainly less extreme than many other
republicans
and despite being a very blue state with
a very left-wing state legislature these
sort of
more moderate republicans are frequently
elected governors
of massachusetts we've also reported
that charlie baker is a republican
governor
who has dealt pretty well with
coronavirus i think now things are
starting to
get a little out of hand i think indoor
dining needs to be shut down
and quick because we are back up to 6
700 cases a day
after being down to you know 150 and the
like
but overall charlie baker has done
pretty well with the virus
back when donald trump wanted state
national guard troops
set down to guard the border charlie
baker said i'm not doing it
well the latest news is that charlie
baker is abandoning the republican party
this november at least nationally
and not supporting donald trump putting
out a statement a couple days ago
through his communications director
which said quote the governor
cannot support donald trump for
president and
is focused on seeing massachusetts
through the pandemic
he'll leave the election analysis to the
pundits
now we already knew baker didn't vote
for trump back in 2016. he voted a blank
ballot on the presidency
so this could be a few different things
this could be that charlie baker
understanding that he's potentially on
the ballot for re-election in a couple
years
having one of the highest approval
ratings of any governor on coronavirus
as a republican
in a blue state why would he do
something that could torpedo him
but would it really torpedo him i don't
know massachusetts is a very blue state
but 32 percent of massachusetts voters
did vote for trump
in 2016. now it's important to
understand
a lot of those massachusetts republican
voters are very different than
louisiana republican voters south
carolina republican voters
but still it's not clear that supporting
trump
would torpedo charlie baker's shot at
re-election it wouldn't help but it's
not clear it would torpedo it
so it could really be a personal
moral objection to donald trump and less
about calculated politics but either way
it's very interesting because
it is not common that republican
governors don't support
the republican candidate for president
it's equally uncommon that democratic
governors wouldn't support the
democratic candidate for president
but you can really see it in a couple
different ways now
the the other thing i think is important
to uh
mention here is that these
republican governors like charlie baker
are often seen as weird
by republicans in other parts of the
country there's a really interesting
reality we have to
come to terms with which is that charlie
baker
really represents what republicans used
to be in the 60s and 70s
i would argue that the republicans that
are the weird ones
are the ones that abandoned the school
of thought of people like
you know william f buckley for example
and
now have turned into the sycophantic
lindsey graham
joni ernst types they are really the
wacky ones
you know bill weld another example of a
republican massachusetts governor
who's really a right-leaning libertarian
as an example
and similarly if you look at the
republican governors as well as the
republican electorates in a lot of
these other states you see dramatically
different things and it does reflect the
republicans in the state
brooklyn it happens on the democratic
side as well brooklyn democrats
and south carolina democrats are very
different there's no question about that
and much the same way rural pennsylvania
republicans and boston suburb
republicans
are very different one republican
governor at minimum is abandoning donald
trump
we will see uh if anybody else does in
any case i would expect a donald trump
tweet
or attack of some kind on charlie baker
calling him a rhino a republican in name
only maybe he's already referred to
charlie baker that way
and i just don't remember but doing the
right thing i
i like that charlie baker is doing this
we have a fantastic program for you
today
later on in the show we are going to
talk about
what should happen with the electoral
college what can
change the presidential race at this
late stage
and very importantly will the voter
turnout explosion
actually happen this year we're seeing
way more early voting than we've ever
seen before but we are in a pandemic
where early voting has been encouraged
like it's never been encouraged before
every party every election likes to say
we've we have enthusiasm and we are
going to win on record turnout this year
is it actually going to happen all of
those and your calls
will be discussed later on in the
program make sure you're following me
on twitter at d pacman and we will take
a quick break and be back right after
this
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do
is take thousands of popular nonfiction
books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in
15 minutes blinkist makes sure that
you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks a month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
welcome back to the show remember the
best way to support the david pakman
show
is to grab a membership at
joinpakman.com it's quick
it's easy it feels good and it's really
really cheap
particularly if you use the coupon code
2020 now you'll save
66 percent let's hear from some viewers
and listeners we are going to take some
calls via
the david pakman show discord
davidpakman.com
slash discord that's d d-i-s-c-o-r-d
there are so many people very very
interested in getting on and it's it's
hard to know
uh where to start even but i think today
we are going to first start with
j a from long beach j a from long beach
can you hear me
uh can you hear me yeah what's going on
j.a oh gosh
this is my second time calling um i
pretty much
my first call was about you know bernie
and his um
like what were his chances of winning
that's why i asked you that before
right that was a while ago yeah that was
a while ago and now uh
i i just i never i didn't think about
the questions i was
i was just gonna say uh um
i really like your show i really like it
it's it's been a while i remember like
um
like two to three years ago that's when
i heard it and uh
it was uh it pretty much helped me
understand uh things about politics how
they work and all that so
i'm just i'm just thanking you for that
beautiful sorry
i kind of remember that you're doing
great j.a thank you for the kind words
we love it
uh and it is of course very very much
appreciated let's go next to
rob from massachusetts rob from
massachusetts what's going on today
i'm doing good how are you doing doing
well doing well
i just want to say i've been watching
your program for i think
five six months i think i first found
out about you through uh fantano
beauty and um yeah um are you familiar
with uh burlington
by any chance burlington mass or vermont
burlington mass i've been in burlington
mass once
oh you have all right so let me just get
to my question i want to
just want to break the ice a little bit
all right i didn't know if the question
was related to burlington
i was answering it as if it was material
yeah
yeah i should have got to the uh
question so uh my question for you
is uh i've i've kind of been raised to
kind of
think that uh
democrats are bad based on like my
family's beliefs
okay and as i've gotten older i've
noticed that
my own siblings have kind of grown a lot
more aware of
how different in how vastly different
we kind of think in political beliefs so
my question for you
is how do you
kind of stem away from your what
families have taught you in politics and
just be confident with the decisions you
make in politics
this is a very very important question
because there's certainly no question
that
uh people are more likely to
hold the political beliefs that line up
with their parents
as a general rule and of course there's
people that abandon left-wing parents
and become right-wing
and there's people that abandon
right-wing parents and become left-wing
i think the important thing to do is to
separate it
from being a lot of times political and
also religious beliefs
are sort of considered sacred and
different than any other kind of belief
so
there's not much stigma or shame or
concern
typically if your parents grew up liking
american cars
and you think ford chevy and dodge
they're not that great i really prefer
german vehicles or something like that
and i think what's important is if you
feel confident
in that understand that coming to
different conclusions about about
religion or politics if it's based on
facts and empiricism
really is no different now it's easier
said than done because it's much more
likely
that your family is going to judge you
if you have different political beliefs
than they
do whereas if you have a different
opinion about which airline to fly
or what foods taste good or what cars to
buy it's unlikely to create the same
type of rift but if the question is how
to feel confident in your beliefs i
think it's the destigmatizing of
political and religious beliefs so that
you might just
look at the facts in a different way you
might look at facts your parents didn't
look at
and come to different conclusions and
that that is okay and and then the
second piece that's tougher is
figuring out you know if and how it
affects your relationship with with them
and that's tougher to do
no yeah i feel like it might get a
little bit difficult like as
and the uh scenario when i eventually
move out
assuming that things uh pick up once
covid uh clears up
which is hopefully soon we all hope it
will be soon and we all hope it will
happen and uh
you know it it could be a little while
but hopefully not too long rob
no definitely uh thank you again for uh
taking my question
i'm i'm glad that i'm glad that you're
staying strong through all this and uh
congrats on the
million subscriber uh milestone that's a
huge
i know that's like a huge milestone for
a lot of people but i'm happy out of all
out of all the political uh commentators
on youtube i'm glad that you've
made it this far so congrats on that man
thank you and almost now
at 1.1 million subscribers
very very excited i would love to get to
1.1 honestly
by election day i don't know that that's
going to happen
but uh anyway we will we will we will
continue trying and we will see
let's see who else wants to get on today
why don't we go to
um there's just so many people let's go
to casey from
oklahoma city casey from oklahoma city
what's going on
casey i know you're unmuted because i
heard a gonk in the background but you
you were on casey from oklahoma city
can you hear me okay yeah i sort of can
sorry i'm in our office gotta get the
mask on
walk down the hall um yeah so my
question is kind of a hypothetical and
then your
opinion on the matter i generally feel
like
both parties should not attack the court
this is the conversation that's
happening
right now with with barrett
and you know i kind of feel like
the democrats could say yeah we're gonna
pack the court with two we're gonna
we're just gonna even the nomination you
made and then we're gonna add one more
for the one that we
we wanted but i still don't think it's
the right thing to do so i'm just
curious what your thoughts are on it
casey are you using power tools while
you talk to me
uh uh i am in a manufacturing plant so
they are literally power tools okay
that's good i'm glad i'm not going crazy
um so listen here's the thing
i don't think joe biden wants to pack
the court i i think joe biden has
actually been
pretty clear in the past that he it's
not something he wants to do i don't
think joe biden is going to do it
so while i understand the criticism that
he's not being upfront about whether he
would or wouldn't
um your idea of adding two i just don't
think it's something joe biden wants to
do and he's trying to keep the threat of
packing the court to have some leverage
i don't know that it's working barrett
could be confirmed before we know it
but um your idea is an interesting one i
just don't think joe biden has any
interest in it
well and i i don't think it i don't
think we should i mean i like the idea
that the courts are independent but i
don't know how they also can be as we're
all human
um so i mean you also are picking judges
based on their opinions on things
like the aca of course so it's it's a
weird argument because they say well it
shouldn't be political but
you're obviously rushing this through
before they you know see the case on
what november 10th i think it is
yeah if uh if if if judges
merely interpreted the law in a robotic
way
and spat out a response you would have
robots do it you wouldn't
you wouldn't put people in there and
you're correctly pointing out that of
course their politics matter there's no
question about it and you know playing
these games that they play during
confirmation hearings about
no i would simply look at the law and
come out with the right answer i'm just
a
i i just reflect what the law is i don't
come up with anything uh of course
that's not the way it works
right but that that was on top of mine
appreciate the uh taking the call and
wish you the best all right casey i'll
let you get back to the manufacturing
there
i uh very very much appreciated let's go
next
to who else do we want to go to
how about um oh you know who was on
let's go to shonda from
toronto shonda what's what's going on hi
uh this is actually shonda from toronto
ohio
okay i i assume i assumed it was canada
but it's not
no no uh i realized that after i put it
no problem it's still allowed okay
well i just wanted to um
kind of talk about uh the the stimulus
package sure a situation um
so i live in a rural community in ohio
a lot of people are laid off um i know a
lot of people have a lot of opinions
about uh
the gas and oil industry but it's big
and people have and that industry is
just
dead here right now yeah so people are
really struggling
and it just is so disheartening to hear
that you know maybe it's a possibility
no stimulus package until
uh february is that what do you think
about that is that what's gonna happen
it is completely plausible yeah we
earlier in the week we reviewed nancy
pelosi's interview with wolf blitzer
where she lost her temper with wolf and
started attacking him and and really
you know she's right to be frustrated
but the frustration shouldn't be with
wolf's questions
it should be with with republicans and
trump because you would think well
listen if trump really is willing to do
1.8 trillion why not take it and nancy
pelosi's argument is it doesn't actually
really deal
with xyz the counter would be well get
the 1.8 trillion to people now before
the senate goes on vacation then we have
an election then we've got until
january inauguration and it could be
february but i i do think that it is
completely plausible that there will be
no more stimulus money until february
if at all if by february there is
if unemployment ticks down another
couple points by february
and the vaccine starts being distributed
there may be no more stimulus money
that's that's also a possibility
yeah i thought that too because if it
takes too long maybe
the uh maybe they won't care about it so
much in february maybe it'll be on their
next thing
i mean listen it would be amazing if you
didn't need a stimulus in february but
people are going to be so
upside down on you know credit card
payments
and housing payments and everything by
then that i think it's unlikely that it
wouldn't be necessary
yeah and you know um we live
kind of close to west virginia and they
uh
like half the people there can't afford
their rent right
right it's it's bad it's very bad shonda
because uh you know again the gas and
oil industry is big there
yes and uh you know
everybody's all happy you know low gas
prices and everything else
well yeah i mean you know gas prices
when there's nowhere to go
don't do that much for you low gas
prices when the car's been repossessed
don't do that much for you
yeah that that's exactly what what my
thought is on it and
you know just it it's uh it's rough it's
rough and
you know people say we'll just go get a
job well uh
it's kind of hard to do that when you
don't have any place to apply
it is indeed it is indeed shonda thank
you so much i appreciate hearing from
you
we are going to go to a quick break uh
if you're holding
don't hang up because we're going to the
break is going to feel like nothing to
the people on hold and we'll be right
back on and take more of your calls
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way is through
membership which includes the world
famous
bonus show as well as commercial free
audio and video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpackman.com
coupon code saves you 40 percent vote
soon eighteen
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
let's hear from a few more people on the
david pakman show discord
at davidpakman.com slash discord that is
d-i-s-c-o-r-d
let me bring on our friend pedro
from colombia pedro como estas
hola mr pacman can you hear me
i i can hear you yes hold uh mr pacman
it's been a long time you know
uh i got the corona a few months ago
and then it was kind of sad and then my
my wife she left me for a little bit but
quality
so you do speak some sp you actually do
speak some spanish it sounds like
oh yeah mr fakman i i speak spanish but
i try to
speak english too okay and
what were your symptoms quality
oh you know my my head hurt you know
i was like oh no i can't can't get up
here
today you know
oh i don't know it was like a hundred
or something mm-hmm okay
but you know i feel better now and you
know my
my wife she was gone so she didn't get
sick it was just
me and perrito you know now when you say
your wife left you
she left you just temporarily while you
had the covid or she just you're no
longer with her
oh she was like man she just got mad at
me
and you know she but she was i'm trying
to understand she was mad you had the
virus or she was mad about something
else
oh she gets mad at me for a lot of
things that that was one reason she got
mad at me
right and remember remind me where in
ecuador are you from
no from colombia oh from colombia okay
very good
but i mean i'm in texas and i'm looking
forward to
buying winning taxes my
question for you is do you think biden
has a chance in
texas listen i think he has a chance and
joe biden recently made the decision to
start spending a bunch more money in
texas
he's also sending kamala harris down
there so i think by
it's close enough that biden has
determined it's worth making a play
for it uh i i if you say bet money david
who wit just even money who wins texas
i still think trump wins texas but
forcing trump to have to defend it
is a great thing oh yes you know i hope
i hope i didn't win i hope kamala harris
when she's kind of cute you know
right well you know i i appreciate
talking to you mr pacman i love your
your discord and there's some very nice
people there
all right pedro from and you're from el
capital right you told us
no mr pacman i just had a headache that
day i didn't remember where i'm from
where are you from in colombia i have a
headache now and i don't remember where
i'm right wrong you
you'll tell me next time okay all right
pedro from colombia
is shot out of a cannon today let's go
next to nikki from
germany nikki from germany what's going
on
hello david yes can you listen uh can
you hear me
i can hear you oh that's fine um
first i want to thank you for all the
live streaming you do
my pleasure yes it's uh
amazing what's happening in the us and
we are terrified
absolutely absolutely nikki
uh are you scared if trump wins
are you scared for your safety or
i i have a feeling they will go to the
to
um persecute the left or
i worry about the same thing nikki and
in fact uh earlier this week on the
bonus show
i'm sorry on in the voicemail segment a
viewer called in and asked
what preparations are being made and
without getting into a lot of detail
we have established duplicate studios
they look
exactly the same but they are in various
bunkers in different parts of the united
states such that we would be able to
retreat to other studios if it became
necessary
there are actually some progressive
hosts who they
they don't even live where they public
if you look at their wikipedia pages and
their facebook profiles
it says they live in one place they
really live somewhere
completely different so there's a lot
going on behind the scenes nikki
from this from the standpoint of saying
yes i can understand
it's just so or i don't have words
really
yeah now let me ask you this from
germany
do you see the us and do you pity us
do you laugh at us what is the primary
emotion
i feel sorry i really feel sorry for all
the people
who might lose their health insurance
and
who can't pay their rent and yeah it's
terrible really i just feel sorry and
i'm not laughing about the us
i laugh at trump yes he's yeah a
laughingstock
but he's also very dangerous right
so we have this sister we was hitler and
uh
it's just so much the same and it's
terrifying i
thought this would never happen again
but wow
people just don't learn well nikki let's
hope for the best best and check in
after the election
okay yes all right i wish you all the
best
good luck thank you there's nikki from
germany hope to be back in germany
very very soon uh it would be it would
be great to do it
let's go to mackenzie from
mackenzie from it's cut off mckenzie
from somewhere hold on a second
um mackenzie you are unmuted uh
mackenzie from cat is it california
mackenzie is self-muted all right i'm
gonna have to turn the mute back on that
failed that did not work
let's go to uh let's go to josephine
josephine what's going on with you today
where are you calling in from
hi hi david yes hi
uh josephine from australia colleague
how are you
i am i'm fine i'm okay
thank you how are you doing well thank
you that's great considering all the
information that's
going in yeah my question i suppose you
could call it a question
yeah per se
is uh with regard to um eric trump
yes and he is i'll call it a spot
on the hang on uh you there oh i'm here
josephine
yeah yeah his spot on broadcast news and
you commented on that
uh segment today was it yesterday
yeah it was a couple days ago eric trump
was on over it was actually over the
weekend that eric trump was on abc with
jonathan carl and he made very little
sense
oh uh sense uh no
it's i'm i'm actually gonna say like
putting that aside
yeah putting all the crap that came out
of his mouth aside
the fact that um
he actually has a voice like who he
who is he he's he's known he's
donald trump's son and he is commenting
on the
state of affairs in america yeah okay
and also as you said
it it is kafka-esque yes it was kafka
and not only that um you know it's
nepotism the height of nepotism
turned up to 11 right
yeah um because
he shouldn't why is he speaking i mean
okay fine an advisor from the white
house that has no relationship
or obviously they'll have bias maybe
bill barr
fine okay he can he can lie and talk
as donald trump does but not his son
eric
right now josephine did you did you have
any question you wanted to run by me on
this topic i agree with you 110
yeah okay okay okay so
i just wanted to ask you i suppose
do you think that the majority of people
can see
the problem with this with with eric
trump being on tv
well yeah i mean it's you know america
is
is is not a family business
right and
yeah i mean do you do you know do you
understand what i mean
josephine i love it i think many people
do see the problem with it
and and many people uh don't and and
they don't care
so i think that unfortunately you know
you've got a mix of everything here in
uh here in the united states
and we're gonna have to do our best to
uh to to remove it but josephine i gotta
move on because i do have a lot of
people who want to
very very strongly get on let's go next
to lamar from london
lamar from london you're on what's going
on
hey um thanks for picking up my pleasure
um
so i've seen your video with uh jesse
lee peterson
yeah um great job on that um what's
really entertaining um
i was wondering you seem to be on the
same page with
conservatives like pandas owens and
kind of playing identity politics and
they like to
kind of make it out as if that's
something that people on the left like
to do
um i'm really curious as to like whether
you would
interview candice owens or other like
conservatives like larry elder and so
forth and kind of confront them on that
because
i mean listen um candace owens we we've
had
there's been so much back and forth with
candace owens i was as far as i knew i
was supposed to be on a panel with her
at politicon a couple years ago and then
she said she was never even asked and
was never even going to politicon at
this point i don't know that she would
be willing to talk to me but i would
gladly host her on my program or or
appear on hers
larry elder okay maybe i don't know that
larry elder is the most relevant to my
audience but i have no opposition and
principle to it
yeah definitely i just think that would
be really interesting because i think
her
and uh even charlie kirk for instance is
they
they change their arguments quite
frequently and they're not very
consistent
no but they're you know their fan bases
think that they're the most intelligent
people in the world
um yes i would just it would be really
interesting to hear
something i was actually thinking the
other day i saw a totally delusional
clip of charlie kirk yelling about how
you know basically your life depends on
voting trump it was it was crazy
but i i was wondering like what happens
to charlie kirk if trump loses you know
yeah exactly i mean he was um he was
found out the other day i
feel like having this fake group um with
turning point or something like that um
i think i read about it and
they were kind of swaying people not to
vote or something like that they were
astroturfing somewhere yeah who can even
keep up
it's hard to even know hey lamar real
quick question
um how can can you clarify for me
in in in british english as you speak
proper british
english what is the pro how do you
pronounce that the
the virus uh you know we call it it's
spelled c-o-v-i-d how do you pronounce
that
uh covet oh you do oh wow okay my god
all right i guess people are right i've
been
all right well uh lamar on that note uh
i i appreciate the phone call i've been
duly
duly humbled and i appreciate you
pronouncing that for me
thanks great talking to you all right
there is lamar from london
very very exciting i see mckenzie is
very aggressively saying that they were
not given a full opportunity
uh you are on right now mackenzie did
you have something you wanted to talk
about
yes i i apologize i had the thing uh
deafened so
all right very good what can we do for
you um so i just had a question
um i'm not sure if you talked about this
before or if it's like important to you
um
i'm jewish too and i was just wondering
um what your
i don't know observation is on
anti-semitism on the left
so i've been interested in like the
online left um
world for a while and i i feel a little
bit
shut out because it just seems like
people are denying
that jews are also indigenous to the
region
um and saying that they dislike zionists
but the vast majority of american
jews overall are zionists and i feel
like there are a lot of double standards
with
um you know saying israel is not real
um but then also you know not having a
problem with like lebanon
or egypt when it was created uh via the
british mandate too uh yeah so there's a
lot i mean these are all different
issues so there's the there's the
geopolitical
in terms of one's opinion about middle
east politics that's one thing
i think and there are very healthy
debates to be had there
i think you know we're very familiar
with how right-wing
anti-semitism manifests in the united
states and and people on the left tend
to understand that and and sort of uh
call it out uh there is unfortunately
left-wing anti-semitism as well which
takes on a different tone and tenor
it includes sort of writing off
oppression and discrimination against
jewish people which has been a constant
around the world for thousands of years
there is the sort of writing jews off in
the united states as
privileged whites when that completely
ignores that
um basically all european discrimination
against jews over the last hundred years
is predicated on the idea that jews are
not indeed
uh considered white we saw the women's
march stuff where
jewish women were not considered
intersectional enough to be
part of the leadership of the women's
march so there's a lot of left-wing
anti-semitism
it's more uh i don't want to call it
nuanced because that almost makes it
sound good it's
it's more hidden uh and
i think that's that's where i would sort
of put it but yes
left and right wing anti-semitism both
exist they are different things they
look different and i've been talking
about it for years
yeah um so i was just wondering so like
um
i just feel like it's becoming more of a
bigger issue so like with the dsa
like it's a fairly large socialist
left-wing organization
yeah um and i just feel like they also
have been like writing off
um you know
uh anti-semitism or like ignoring
you know jewish perspectives on israel
for example
i know that i know less about because as
someone who is not a socialist
i don't really do or i don't observe dsa
or or know too much about it so i
wouldn't be able to really say anything
about that
okay gotcha yeah thank you um and i also
just wanted to
share my opinion um on the jamie
harrison versus lindsey graham
uh race too because i am from south
carolina yeah real quick
yeah um i i just feel like a lot of um
i i i think uh lindsey graham's gonna
win 90
of the chance um i think it's gonna
happen um
i i just feel like there's not enough uh
long-term hype about jamie harrison
yeah i mean i if you again if you force
me to bet i bet graham wins but i think
it'll be close enough that there's
certainly
that jamie harrison certainly has a shot
and it would be amazing to defeat
lindsey graham
i totally agree you know all right
mckenzie great to hear from
mckenzie from south carolina that is all
the time i have today so if people are
still holding i i do
i grovel at your feet that i will be
unable to get to any more today
but uh there will be streams where there
may be opportunities to call in we will
go to a break on the podcast
the tv show and the radio show and be
back with plenty more
momentarily the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going
is through patreon where you can pledge
as little as one dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about them
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
all right let's get into some perfect
audience questions for the week very
election
relevant the first one is david can you
explain is the electoral college
good or bad because i hear different
people
saying different things well it should
come as no surprise that different
people have different opinions about the
electoral college but
in order to answer the question is the
electoral college good or bad you have
to first understand what the point of
the electoral college is and number two
what one considers good or bad may
depend on where they sit politically
so let's kind of build up our
understanding of this in the united
states
if a hundred million people vote 55
million vote for one candidate 45
million vote for another candidate
it is not guaranteed that the one with
the 55 million votes
won why is that because we don't have a
national
popular vote we have an electoral
college system where each state is worth
a certain number of
votes or points as they were the first
to get to 270
points or electoral votes wins so you
could win some states by crazy huge
popular vote margins
win the popular vote but only have 265
electoral votes a different candidate
could have fewer total votes but win
enough
electoral votes to win and in fact
that is what happened in the year 2000
with george w bush and al gore
uh and it is what happened in uh did it
happen in 2004 it obviously happened
recently with donald trump
in uh in 2016. so what
we see is that the electoral college
gives disproportionately more or less
power to certain states
in deciding the outcome of the election
and by virtue of doing that the voters
in those states have relatively more
or less power in total because a vote in
california
is not equally likely to decide the
outcome as is a vote in for example
pennsylvania or florida
good why do we have this system
initially the idea of the electoral
college was
listen if candidates if we have a
national popular vote
candidates will spend all their time in
the most populated areas
and california and new york will decide
the election
that's where candidates will go and they
will ignore the small
and rural states well all you've really
done
with the electoral college system is
change that around
so that now the states that decide the
election are a handful
of so-called battleground states
including but not limited to
florida wisconsin pennsylvania michigan
north carolina arizona
etc so in particular
in 2020 when listen i don't need the
candidate
coming to where i am we have enough
media
we have enough internet where i can make
a completely informed decision
i don't care if the candidate never goes
on the campaign trail at all quite
frankly
if i can understand policy differences
and sort of understand who who
the candidates are so i do believe that
the electoral college is outdated
first and foremost i do believe the
electoral college
has created the opposite of the problem
they wanted to solve by
basically making it so candidates are
ignoring the very populated areas
but most importantly when you say is it
good or bad what i go to
is whether the electoral college better
reflects the will of the people than a
national popular vote
and the answer is no more than
two million more people voted for
hillary clinton than for donald trump in
2016. now you could say well if it was a
national popular vote the election would
have been run differently
run it differently than as a candidate
fine but way more people wanted hillary
and yet donald trump is president and
fundamentally
the electoral college system is one of
the many
systems that gives a structural
advantage to republicans
it is republicans who have benefited
from having their candidate win despite
losing the popular vote multiple times
now
it is republicans who benefit from the
sort of baseline reality that
conservatives are more likely to live in
rural areas
than are liberals merely because of
preferences
and our system disproportionately gives
power to
rural states when it comes to the
electoral college and
importantly in the senate the senate is
another way
in which our government is stacked
against the left
each state gets two senators the highest
population states tend to be blue
leading states left-leaning states
and so you have a situation i'm thinking
back to the election where something
like
the senators representing only 17
percent of the population
have half of the votes in the senate
that's crazy the senate is fundamentally
undemocratic
so to step back i do believe the
electoral college is a negative
influence
on the will of the people being
expressed and who becomes president of
the united states
i do believe that it should be changed
and when you look at some of the data
the 10 least populated states plus dc
have a population that's three percent
of the country
and they have almost seven percent of
the electors they are more than
two x over represented and we can slice
and dice it in other ways to give
these kind of notable examples but i
believe the electoral college
has to go i think it is a bad influence
on the united states system
of picking presidents if you disagree
with me let me know i would love to hear
from you
hey david at this point in time what can
change the presidential race
so i'm going to answer this question
without weighing in on
whether the race is over because it
doesn't we've talked about
the poll the national polls look very
good for biden but biden is not doing
quite as well
in wisconsin michigan and pennsylvania
compared to where hillary was at this
point four years ago
whatever each of us believes to be the
situation right now
the question is what could dramatically
change it um
i think that at this point in time we
really are looking only at
big big issues like a health issue for
one of the candidates if one of the
candidates
were to be truly very ill where it would
be unclear that they would
make it to the inauguration i do think
that that would change
how people decide to vote a major
credible crime allegation against one of
the candidates i don't mean trump at
rallies saying
biden and obama spied on me and they
should be indicted that's not what i
mean by a major credible
trump hasn't even said what crime was
committed uh supposedly when he says
that but
like a real story that takes over about
wow
trump or biden accused of x y or z
remember many of the sexual assault
allegations against biden sorry against
trump were certainly crimes at the time
and you can talk about statute of
limitations or whatever
didn't make a difference in 2016. i
don't believe the third debate if it
happens
will change anything again unless
there's a major failure by someone a
medical event during the debate
some you know if trump starts yelling
the n-word
during the debate i do think it would
have an impact i know his
his core base might not care but there
are people
who are just slightly over on the trump
side
who you know if trump starts calling
black people the n word for example or
a jews the k word or something i think
that that that would have an impact
um some people have written to me and
said david don't you think joe biden
being unwilling to say whether or not he
will pack the court don't you think that
that's hurting him
i don't and i'll tell you why um on
balance
you might say if a candidate clearly
isn't answering a question directly
it hurts them and so there may be some
way
in which some people aren't pleased that
joe biden
is not willing to say whether he will or
won't pack the court
there's a different side to the strategy
which is
by not saying it he maintains it as a
threat to republicans which
may be useful whereas if biden says i
won't do it
they're off the hook and if biden says i
will do it then they just campaign
against biden because biden says he will
pack the court
now my belief is biden will not pack the
court
you can go back and see biden's previous
statements about packing the court
i don't think biden has any intention of
packing the court
much to the dismay of many people on the
left
but i it's not so clear to me that biden
not answering that question is really
doing damage i
certainly don't think it's going to
change the outcome of the election so
this close to the election particularly
with so many people having already voted
it's very difficult to change what the
outcome is going to be now
the outcome ultimately may not reflect
the will of the people
because of foul play because of foul
play with absentee ballots because of
the use of lawyers and courts to try to
stop the counting of said ballots
so on and so but that's that's something
that is not about
events on the campaign trail and if you
take
alan lichtman's approach to predicting
elections which is a qualitative
approach
it's less about this happened in a
debate it's more circumstantial what's
going on in the country
he would argue that the cake is already
baked he happens to think biden will win
he may be right he may be wrong
biden biden may win the popular vote and
yet not win electorally in which case
did alan lichtman get it right or not we
could debate that but the idea would be
this late in the game only a candidate
becoming incapacitated
would change the situation because with
a qualitative analysis the circumstances
in the country over the last four years
are what they are and that is what will
determine the outcome
we will have to wait and see and we
won't have to wait that much longer
david for all the talk about voter
turnout will it actually happen this
year
this is a great question because every
election someone says
it's a turn it's turnout it's a turnout
election in a mathematical sense
when 45 of the country doesn't vote in
presidential elections
turnout alone can flip an election sure
it's not about
convincing people about one candidate
over another it's about
if nearly half the country doesn't vote
finding people who agree with you and
getting them to vote is a potentially
mathematically viable strategy does it
ever actually happen well
it's often underwhelming particularly
when candidates have counted on
young voters who love me are going to
rocket me to victory
bernie is an example and then it doesn't
happen so it doesn't
it doesn't always happen however we have
a few interesting data points
in 2018 the midterm had a much higher
turnout than the 2014 midterm
and the 2010 midterm if you see that as
an indicator for what will happen in
2020 as far as turnout goes
it suggests big turnout in 2020.
the other side of this is if you look at
how many people have already voted as of
today
it's millions and millions when it was
very few at this point in 2016.
some are saying that means turnout is
off the wall and it's probably bad for
trump
the counter is multiple states most
states half the states i don't know the
number but because of the pandemic
many many states have expanded and
encouraged
absentee ballots and absentee voting so
it's not that naturally without anything
being different
the number of early votes have exploded
by orders of magnitude they've exploded
but because we have a pandemic and
states have actually gone out of their
way like they've never done before
to get people to vote absentee or or to
vote early so i don't think that's
really the sign
i think we're going to have to wait and
see trump has been repeating the left
has no enthusiasm
that seems very wrong and if you look
even from the past weekend at early
voting lines people waiting in line
12 hours to vote part of the reason
they're waiting that long is of course
early voting has been hampered
particularly in democratic areas
we've seen reductions in polling places
and people thrown off voter rolls so
they get there and they're not on the
list and
okay fine but there does not seem to be
a shortage of enthusiasm and in the end
it is really hard to get people
who aren't interested in politics to
vote
it's tough it really is tough nearly
half the country isn't interested enough
to have voted in 2016.
that's a very difficult situation it's
an opportunity
if you can activate people but it is a
very very difficult thing to do that's
where my head is right now i do think we
will see
record turnout partially because the
population is bigger than ever but i
believe there is enthusiasm
is it going to be a blow out of the
water record
turnout i think it'll be record turnout
i don't think it'll be
one guy called and said he expects i
think he said 160 million votes
uh i i don't think we're gonna get 160
million votes
at all if we do i will eat my hat i
don't have any hats so i can make that
promise but
um i i do think we will see record turn
out we have a great bonus show planned
for you today
get instant access instant
by signing up at joinpackman.com
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's sponsor is blinkist the app that
lets you
read or listen to an entire non-fiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
for free
and save 25 percent off of a
subscription
when you go to blinkist.com david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video